are you hot you're not hot right i'm hot
yeah
not not hot is it heated i mean unless
you're hot and ready to go sexy
[ __ ] i'm glad you said it
don't mean you can say it as a man it's
okay it shows your man that you can look
at another man
yeah
with the three pieces
of course yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
you mean some that's
are just so sexy you have to acknowledge
it yeah yeah you know think about it
yeah let's think about what do they say
tall dark and handsome i am he yeah
[Laughter]
okay let me stop messing around who's
the sexiest man though who's the sexiest
man yeah
second to you uh who would you call it
like uh idris
idris is
[Music]
yeah sexy says
you look like a man you'll walk like a
man you talk like a man
you're a man
so idris is number one yeah he's just my
boy that's cause i heard people say you
kind of look like each so i gotta put
him up yeah yeah yeah right they do that
but yeah yeah
hottest white dudes oh yeah yeah who's
this hottest white dude sexiest white
dude in this room
[Laughter]
brad pitt is a sexy
[Laughter]
he's sectioning tom brady you're not
impressed by tom brady no no no nobody
tell me a little goofy no no but but tom
i always say this i measure men in
distance travel
right so in distance travel i'll give it
to tom okay because when i saw tom that
first picture coming out at the combine
that does not look like a man
that should get that wife
he earned his
if somebody had taken you
and put a picture of tom yeah and any
other quarterbacks up there yeah that
first picture and say
go get your family y'all gotta bet every
dime y'all have on which one of these do
i never make it in the nfl yeah
everybody will put every dime on top
to where he is sexy and he i don't know
how he even got to look as good as he
looks you know from where he was but you
think he got some like some lip fillers
or something like that you think he's he
got the brazilian butt lift oh i i think
he got a lot of pocket fillers with
those super bowl
yeah
yeah
and for some reason for some reason
money always makes you sexy
makes you look better it does trust me
go back
you weren't always working with eddie
murphy
oh eddie looked good still it looks good
now yeah yeah but when eddie first
started out
yeah but he was like 17 that was a boy
damn it is sexy yeah
man that's a funny dude yeah 100
have you met eddie before
uh
i don't think i've ever met him really i
don't think i've ever met him but i
would love him you guys doing a movie
with him right now yeah yeah what is it
like working with eddie man um
it's fun
he's not as social as you let's say that
yeah yeah he's not as social
eddie's in his own world man you've been
famous since he's 18 years old yeah he
must be i don't know he's always been
the most famous guy since he's 18 so
like it's it's people get uncomfortable
around him
you know what i'm saying right right
right because he's at it yeah and we we
could have been uncomfortable around you
but you came in with so much energy and
positivity i don't want to kill that i
want him to kill you yeah i'm talking
about sexy guys yeah i'm coming and
that's what i want to kill it to make
the rule right
you know what i'm saying everybody
and it's just out of respect
also you got to fight for your normalcy